peu
des centaines de kilomètres de la ville
la plus proche en plein désert du ténéré
inattendue les salines de fâcher le
passage obligé de toutes les caravanes
de sel qui traversent le désert depuis
des milliers d'années
le sel ces quelques cristaux qui
conserve l'indispensable mais aussi le
plus rare l'eau
les années passent
rien ne change les nomades restent les
mêmes ils sont caravaniers de père en
fils
ils se transmettent l'école du désert
pour l'affronter un jour tout seul
[Musique]
voilà trente jours que nous marchons
dans le désert
nos journées se ressemblent toutes nous
partons très tôt le matin et nous nous
arrêtons au coucher du soleil pour
vérifier le chargement des chameaux à la
nuit tombée
nous repartons pendant la traversée nous
ne dormons presque jamais il ne faut pas
perdre de temps car nous devons
économiser l'eau et le fourrage
[Applaudissements]
n
j'avais 20 ans quand je suis devenu
macho man au chef de la caravane c'est
ton père qui t'a tout appris oui c'est
lui qui m'a transmis son savoir mais
comment te re perd tu parmi toutes ces
dunes
elles se ressemblent toutes ce n'est pas
compliqué pour s'orienter le jour il
faut tracer son cap entre chaque dune et
le suivre tout le temps et la nuit ce
sont les sept étoiles de la pléiade qui
nous guide vers la paix
à damas selon sana
dans la hiérarchie des déserts le chef
s'appelle le madougou
il est le seul à connaître le chemin que
doit suivre la caravane sur lui repose
toute la confiance de ses hommes de lui
dépend le succès du voyage vendre le sel
10 fois son prix et faire vivre sa
famille pendant plus d'un an
rien ne pourra remplacer cette logique
implacable fana ne sera jamais le
dernier madougou du désert
[Musique]
quel est ton rêve car ni région le chef
se rivent et d'après toi quand
pourra-t-il de venir je ne sais pas
quand je serai diriger mais que
préfères-tu suivre la caravane ou rester
au campement
je préfère ce travail était copain ta
famille il te demande pas tu préfères le
désert oui rien n'est plus beau que deux
heures
[Musique]
dr me fait peur parfois
la moindre erreur peut être fatale je
pense souvent à mes amis qui un matin a
dû s'éloigner du groupe pour rassembler
ses chameaux et alors qu'est ce qui lui
est arrivé est bien loin du départ de la
caravane
les autres ne se sont pas aperçu de son
absence et quand il est arrivé au point
de rassemblement
il s'est retrouvé tout seul il a dû être
pris de panique il a voulu suivre les
traces mais malheureusement il a pris
celle de la veille il est parti en sens
inverse
nous l'avons cherchée pendant cinq mois
et puis un jour c'est une tribu touareg
qui a retrouvé son corps à côté de son
sabre
[Musique]
nous avons chargé les chameaux et ils se
sont mis à marcher toute la nuit sous
les étoiles brillantes l'immensité du
désert mais menacer les mettait en garde
et pourtant je les traversées les filles
de mon pays
les chanteurs ont jamais je ne suis pas
arrivé à temps et septième jour je serai
là j'appelle ces vrais loups et
verdoyant avec les chameaux qui danse le
tmd
[Musique]